[Applaudissements]
qu'en sera-t-il de tous et je t'aime que
tu me suis hautain quand je n'aurai plus
même chemin de vie sera plus coté tu
auras pitkowski au rapido je reviendrai
ce pauvre et qui ne rate plus ma dignité
qui restera sauveur pendant des piges
j'ai attendu que ma vie change
puis j'ai fini par comprendre que c'est
elle qui attendaient que je change
combien de salles conviendra la vente je
me range tes coeur et le cerveau dans
l'eau ça sont des endroits tellement
étrange je t'aiderai un maire comme lé
fleuve le ton à la mer jean vander la
tumeur qui n'a rien
papa est parti j'ai même pas eu grande
rendre fiers j'espère que tu es tu me
crois qu'ils font sens mais de grand
mère qu'est ce que je fais c'est pour
sortir la famille du piège mauvais
garçon toujours absente hauteur du
presse on est déjà dans ce teaser oeuvré
jusqu'à la mort aujourd'hui c'est moi
tiens souhaitant échanger plus hardcore
mais ceux habitués habitués habitués
habituée habitués habitués habitué à vis
tu es habitué à mieux
si tu es habitué habitués il ya des
siècles mais sans cesse repoussée dans
les champs et aujourd'hui je claque
d'être au sort sur les chances euros sur
le compte me donne l'illusion que ça
j'ai chanté la vérité c'est que l'argent
virton
dis moi ce que je vais laisser par tous
les actes que j'aurais posé cheveux qui
s'envole de moi comme de celui qui aura
toujours du bébé si je sais je vais te
marc muller des choses car ici par aucun
on dit que l'amour ici l'amour et ça
l'amour est mort
moi je dis plein pour les simples
l'excès le désir qui fait désordre et
que les causes ne sont que des
conséquences d'autres causes
sauf que là hurle ça le rêve que de voir
autre chose car j'y suis trop habitués
habitué à me tuer
mais tu es habitué habitués habitués
habitués habitués
si tu es habitué à des tués et du monde
je te dirai qui tu es qui tue habitués
habitué à me tuer
est habitué habitué
[Musique]
mais tu
du coup
plus
je
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai l'habitude
j'ai envie
/
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]